I think to some extent the answers here are debatable,
but the best answer that I would give to this question is
definitely a software under test that interacts directly with hardware devices
would consider the timing of inputs important.
Also definitely software that interfaces with other machines on a network
might consider the timing of inputs important.
Software under test that's multi-threaded won't necessarily
depend on the time at which inputs are delivered,
but it certainly might, and finally,
I would not consider software under test that prints time values into a log file
to necessarily depend on the timing that its inputs are delivered.
It's this kind of software--of which there are many examples--
a software that does care about time values because it's printing them
but probably its logic doesn't depend on these time values
because they're just being output to a device, and they're not being
depended on in any meaningful way.
Again, your mileage may vary on this, but my opinion is that
a, b, and c are the best answers.